hi everybody I'm Rachel and I lead our
customer marketing here at posit it was
so nice to see so many of you last week
at the conference and thank you to
everybody who joined us both in person
and virtually a lot of our time was
focused on last week's conference as you
could imagine so rather than skipping
the session this month we're just going
to do things a little bit different at
last week's conference Joe Roberts gave
a talk on package security that I
thought would be helpful as part of our
workflow demos here I recorded this part
because I'm actually on vacation this
week but Ryan and Joe will be hanging
out with you all in the chat right here
so if you have any questions today or
maybe follow-up questions from last week
you can ask them in the YouTube chat and
we also have a slider link where you can
ask them anonymously too um and I've
shown that slid link here on the screen
but thank you again for joining us and
I'll turn it over to Joe
hi I'm Joe Roberts and I'm a product
manager here at posit and one of the
most common questions I get asked
especially by it administrators and
security teams is how to make sure the
public packages that their data
scientists want to use are safe so today
we're going to explore that topic and
we're going to start with an overview of
the main public package repositories
used by data scientists working in R and
python
to understand how they work and more
importantly how they differ in their
approaches to package publishing we'll
also explore some of the more common
types of security risks in using public
packages and we'll look at strategies to
mitigate those risks using tools like
posit package manager so let's get
started and uh let's take a look at the
main public package repositories for
data
science cran is the primary repository
for R packages uh bioconductor is also
widely used for R packages primarily in
data science life sciences and on the
python side the python package index or
pii um cran and bioconductor take a
similar approach to packages and if
you've ever submitted a package to be
published on cray you know exactly how
stringent those requirements are each
package has to pass a comprehensive set
of checks to ensure the package is
properly formed and documented builds
properly doesn't cause any other
packages to fail um most importantly
from a security standpoint these
packages must be submitted entirely as
Source codes so there's full
transparency of what is contained within
the package and it will it will go
through a a actual human verification
before being published it's like the
exclusive club with the bouncer out
front where they may not make sure you
can dance but they definitely are going
to make sure you you're welled rest
before letting you
in in contrast pii takes the opposite
approach pii is much more like Wikipedia
a completely open repository where
anyone can create an account and publish
packages both in Source or binary
packages uh which then become instantly
available to everyone around the world
this isn't necessarily a bad thing as it
does make a far wider array of packages
available though it does do pose some
additional security risks that we'll
have to take a closer look
at so let's start with the security
risks now and the First Security risk is
around the more fundamental question of
package quality or does this package
accurately do what it claims to do and
that's not always an easy question to
answer especially if you're not a domain
expert but there are some other more
objective factors you can look at to
help you assess quality things like the
number of package downloads or how many
other people are using this package uh
the author's reputation is this package
author well known in the community do
they have a lot of other well-used
packages uh that they've
published uh is this package well
documented are there the functions
documented are there instructional
guides vignettes or other tutorials
available um and how frequently is the
package updated uh when was the last
update is is it actively maintained and
frequently updated with
fixes and finally I mean does the
package include a comprehensive set of
tests to verify that the functionality
is working
correctly so how do we mitigate package
quality concerns well the obvious option
is for someone to carefully scrutinize
the package and make a
determination but as we pointed out
earlier that's not always easy uh
fortunately the community has developed
some tools to help with those
assessments for for example our friends
over at the r validation Hub have
produced an r package called risk metric
that takes these that I just talked
about and many more quality metrics into
account to help you get an objective
assessment of package
quality and once you've done your
reviews and done your assessments and
decided which packages you want to allow
your data scientists to use you can
leverage a feature in posit package
manager called curated repositories
allowing you to create a separate
repository just containing the cran or
pii packages that you've approved for
use in your team or
organization so next let's talk about
what you typically think of when you say
security and that's vulnerabilities and
these can occur at any point in the
package from the source code uh
introduced in compiled code or
vulnerabilities that exist in external
libraries that are used by the
package and it's important to note that
while these are sometimes malicious most
often these are just due to mistakes in
poorly written
code but they're still just as important
to to assess and resolve so mitigating
vulnerabilities is actually a little bit
easier for public packages and that's
because the packages are known published
quantities you don't generally need to
worry about scanning them yourself
because numerous others are scanning
these already already published packages
and Reporting any vulnerabilities on
them so the best resource for mitigating
those are through databases of known
vulnerabilities in Cray's case there are
relatively few vulnerabilities reported
partially due to that strong curation of
packages due to the bouncer at the door
but posit has recently started working
with the r Consortium on building out an
advisory database to track known
vulnerabilities in a standardized format
that was first adopted by the widely
used python packaging advisory database
that's maintained by the python
packaging
Authority both of these now feed into
the osv open- source vulnerability
database that was uh created by Google
and uh and is the best source for
looking up known vulnerabilities in both
R and python packages at this
point once you have that you can
leverage a feature in package manager
called package
blocking and where instead of taking a
bottomup curated approach to approving
every package you want to make available
you can instead go top down and allow
the majority of packages available in
the public repositories giving your
users the most compatibility with
everything that's out there but still
blocking the ones that have known
vulnerabilities and even for blocking
packages that may have uh license open
source licenses that you don't want to
make available inside your
organization now separate from the
security risks in the packages
themselves there are a couple more
malicious risks that prey on weaknesses
in the infrastructure that is used to
distribute these packages we group these
into a c called package confusion which
in simplest terms is all about deceiving
the user into installing the wrong
package so instead of getting the
package they want to use they are
tricked into installing a malicious
package that they don't uh the two risks
will talk about today are typo squatting
and dependency confusion which are some
of the more common ones and most
high-profile ones that we've seen in the
last
year um so I'm going going to start and
give some examples in terms of python
packages as due to those that more
permissive nature of pii these have
shown up in high-profile real world
exploits in the past year uh but the
same cases can apply to the our package
repositories as
well uh so first let's learn about typos
squatting and let's start with you the
data scientist or
developer
and uh we're sitting at our local
machine and
you uh let's say we want to start a
machine learning project and so you want
to grab your tensorflow package from pii
uh you use the standard python
installation utility pip and say pip
install tensorflow which is the command
to install tensorflow equivalent to
doing an install. packages in R to
install a package from the from Cran
and so pip goes out to pii looks for a
package called tensorflow downloads it
installs it into your environment
perfect everything's
fine but now let's uh start again back
in our clean environment we've still got
pii there but this time when we try to
install tensorflow we accidentally make
a typo and had two ends in the name of
the package so pip uh so we have Pip
install tensor flow with two
ends pip goes out and looks for it on
pii and can't find a package by that
name and returns an error uh you notice
you mistype the name fix it and try
again all as well that's what you expect
to happen in those situations and
nothing inherently wrong with that but
here's where things get scary so let's
go back to our our clean environment
here and let's say that some evil person
trying up to no good looks at the most
popular public packages on Pi like
tensorflow which for example gets
downloaded from pii on average about
600,000 times a day globally um and so
they take that and they write their own
malicious package and upload it to pii
with a bunch of different similar names
um that are common things that you might
make type by accident if you were if you
were trying to install the actual
tensorflow package so now we let's take
our same scenario we try to install
tensorflow with two ends in it and make
the same type it was before but instead
of getting an error this time pip goes
out and to pii and finds a malicious
this malicious version that someone put
there and with the same name downloads
it and we've been exploited now because
we've gotten the wrong packageing
here so these are tough to mitigate
against but there are a few things that
we can do and I should point out again
that these are higher risk on with PPI
than on cran due to the more permissive
publishing nature we talked about but
one thing working to our advantages in
that case is that there are many
organizations and companies in the
python Community watching for these
malicious packages now so they're
identified relatively quickly once they
are published usually within a few days
or
less um so the simplest mitigation we
can do is just avoid the latest packages
and updates from public repositories and
give them time to be discovered reported
and blocked or removed and so you know
latest isn't always the safest there and
sometimes it's worth it to sacrifice a
bit of Cutting Edge and
compatibility uh for for in the name of
security so in package manager we can
leverage uh what we call repository
snapshots to easily pin our installation
source to a slightly older versions of
the
repositories we we also get the added
benefit of reproducibility of our
projects by not always getting updates
to the packages that might break our
existing code um and you know it's not a
perfect solution but it's one tool that
can be used together with these other
strategies we're talking about to reduce
our
risks finally I want to talk about a
different variant that prays
particularly on larger teams especially
those who develop and share their own
internal packages to supplement their
work that we call dependency confusion
so let's go back into our clean
environment here where we're now part of
a larger company that has its own
internal packages let's say we're at
posit and we have our internal posit
tool tools package that we use along
with some public packages from Pipi uh
we may even be so sophisticated as to
have our own internal packages in a PPI
like repository so that pip can install
from there so we we want to install
posit tools we add this extra index URL
flag to our internal server uh so so
that it can find where our additional
packages are in reality this is pro this
extra index URL setting is probably set
as part of our system configuration so
we don't have to remember to type it
every time we install something uh but I
include this here because it's is
exactly what would actually happen in
reality so let's say pip goes out looks
for a posit tools package on pii doesn't
find it realizes it's not there so it's
probably an internal package and then
finds it on searches the extra index URL
finds it on our internal repository and
installs it I also need pandas so I do
the same command but in this time it
does find it on pii and installs it just
as expected so everything's perfect
until our Mal our malicious actor steps
in so an evildoer is tosit is targeting
posit employees for example and maybe
guesses that we probably have an
internal package named posit tools
that's not available on pii maybe it you
know a lot of companies have internal
packages like this for connecting to
internal resources database
or other internal sources and so this
malicious actor creates a their own
malicious package and gives it a name
they think that our company might use
internally like posit tools and they
publish it on pii probably with a large
version number in this case like 9.0 uh
so it looks newer than anything else and
now let's we go back to our user who's
trying to say upgrade posit tools they
have installed and so they same as
before have their extra index URL and um
and pip goes out and it sees this newer
version of posit tools not from our
intro repository but available now on
Pipi and it doesn't know any better
assumes that's what you want and
installs it and you've been exploited so
um you know there's lots of variant of
this with not not just directly
installing packages but these packages
being dependencies of other packages and
all of this can happen but in a similar
way here so this uh this one's actually
great because posit package manager can
completely insulate you from this case
using a unified local and public
repository so on that case we put our
all of our packages access all of our
packages through package manager we put
our internal packages in front of the
public package repository and present
that to the user as a single repository
uh taking that decision of which package
to install completely out of Pip's hands
so now when we ask pip to in install
posit tools from our repository here
again it's probably been preconfigured
um so we don't have to add the package
manager address directly but there's
only one that that pip knows to to pull
things from there and so P pip goes out
asks package manager now I need deposit
tools package and package manager knows
hey I'm always going to give you the
internal one and I'm because I know that
the internal package supersedes the the
public one and I will never ever serve
you the public package and we've been
and our case is solved similarly I using
the same same server I asked for pandas
pandas is not in the inter in our
internal package source so package
manager says okay here you go here's the
public one from from pii and still
taking advantage of all of the other
security measures that we can also use
um the Cur curated package blocking or
even repository snapshots can all be
used in conjunction with these local and
uh public repository UniFi
everyone's happy and we've solved and
we've solved at least one of many
security risks that we have to worry
about but um in summary you know the
reality is we can't deny that public
packages do present risks um but really
understanding those risks gives you the
knowledge to manage them uh today we've
talked about some of those strategies
and how tools like posit package manager
can help you reduce some of those
risks
uh and for those of you interested in
learning more about posit package
manager I want to make you aware of our
free hosted service posit public package
manager or p3m we provide a full mirrors
of cray bioconductor and pii that are
free to use uh including historic
snapshots you can take advantage of as
well as the added benefit of our posit
built binary cran packages to make
things easier and faster to install in
your R environment you can find it out
and explore it today at p3m dodev and
definitely reach out to pause it if
you're interested in learning more about
the advanced risk management features we
talked about today and how you can bring
the power of posit package manager into
your own
organization thank you so
much thanks so much Joe it's great to be
able to dive deeper into package manager
today and while we're not jumping over
to a live Q&A session here both Joe and
Ryan Johnson are here hanging out in the
chat to answer any questions that you
have so we'll leave this chat open for
the next 15 minutes or so you can type
your questions into YouTube or use the
slid link for anonymous questions the
short link for that for slido is p
os.it
slemo questions which you can see on the
screen we host these monthly end to end
workflow demos on the last Wednesday day
of every month we'd love to have you
join us again the last 5 months Ryan
Johnson has walked us through workflows
for deploying visualizations to
stakeholders with Dash and shiny shared
how to create scheduled and Company
branded Cordo docs for redundant reports
and also two ways to ensure consistent
and up-to-date data in your work with
apis and also with
pins the link to those previous workflow
demos are also in the YouTube
description below but thank you again
for joining us today Ryan and Joe will
be here in the chat for questions but
have a great rest of the day
everybody